achiou salut je viens après le coc vite
vous parlez ça va être une vidéo très
courte et ça va aller à l'essentiel vous
avez lu le titre je viens faire mon
spectacle chez vous un spectacle
interactif entre vous et moi et
peut-être vos amis et votre famille dans
moins d'une minute je vous dévoile où et
comment et là je prends 60 secondes pour
vous expliquer comment mais blessé
pendant un an et demi de conflit mangez
pas pu faire mon spectacle sur scène ça
m'a clairement arraché le coeur c'est le
truc que je préfère faire ça fait dix
ans que je suis sur scène c'est le plus
important si vous m'avez jamais vu sur
scène vous me connaissez pas vraiment
pour compenser un peu ce manque de scène
j'ai fait deux spectacles en ligne qu'on
avait écrit pour l'occasion ça s'est
bien passé on est il est record de
connexions en france c'était juste un
délire et on m'a dit est ce que tu vas
faire ça toutes les semaines et tout est
en fait la réponse était non parce que
c'est pas non plus la vraie scène tu
vois ce qu'hier c'était génial dans le
côté expérience mais c'est parce que je
veux faire dans ma vie je le live le
vrai laïdi les éphémères il est lé plus
en contact direct voilà mais ce que j'ai
compris par contre c'est que c'était fou
de pouvoir faire un spectacle sans être
vraiment là ça ça c'était quand même
intéressant et un moment donné je me
suis arrêtée trop bien si en plus il
avait du matériel chez eux que j'aurais
pu leur envoyer avant qu'ils avaient pu
manipuler sur été encore plus interactif
et là je me suis dit mais en fait est ce
qu'il ya vraiment besoin que ce soit en
direct ce genre de chose du coup et en
fait non y a pas besoin que ce soit en
direct d'ailleurs mon premier spectacle
confinement thalys met en léger différé
alors j'ai fait des recherches et j'ai
cherché quelque part dans le monde
quelqu'un avait fait un concept de
spectacle mais sans que l'artiste soit
là mais pourtant c'est quand même
interactif et ça se passe de plus chez
la personne et avec du matériel la
réponse est non il y en a on a vraiment
regardé avec mon éditeur tout ça ça n'a
jamais été fait du coup secrètement
depuis le mois d'avril je vous prépare
ça
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
je suis trop fier je suis fier parce que
tous les autres projets que j'ai pu
faire c'est mes projets à moi et j'en
suis extrêmement fier mais c'est des
choses qui existent de personnes
incrites il d'autres personnes en fait
des spectacles de personnes ont fait des
vidéos sa personne l'a fait ok alors je
peux pas vous montrer tout ce qui est
dedans parce que ça va vous gâcher la
surprise mais en gros quand quand tu
ouvres déjà il ya sahel démarquer stop
hockey et seul enveloppe il ya
évidemment plein de choses et dans
l'enveloppé évidemment plein de choses
déjà il ya un dvd d'un spectacle inédit
100 % interactif écrit vraiment pour
l'occasion tournée pour l'occasion dans
un magnifique décor le concept c'est
vraiment je suis enfermée dans votre
télévision et je vous fais un spectacle
à vous qui êtes dans votre canapé en
temps réel mais un spectacle où vous
participez à tous les numéros cas
également un code pour le regarder en
ligne en vod comme ça vous pouvez le
regarder sur internet mais par contre si
vous voulez le regarder chez votre
grand-mère qu'un lecteur dvd et qui n'a
pas de connexion pascal en zone blanche
vous pouvez aussi ça ne change rien
dedans il ya plein d'accessoires des
jeux de cartes des jetons des plaques
est bon je peux je peux pas tout le
détail et parce que ça va tout spoil
mais tout ça ça va vous servir pour
participer au numéro et ça me permettent
d'agir sur vous aussi à distance après
il ya deux choses 1 il ya des délires
par exemple on a mis des tickets de
spectacles que vous pouvez donner à vos
amis pour les habitués à voir le
spectacle chez vous il ya aussi un
bouquin de 32 pages à l'intérieur que
j'ai écrit pour l'occasion qui va vous
servir pour le spectacle mais pas que ça
vous apprend aussi à faire d'autres
trucs de mentalisme vous même après avec
ou sans le matériel de la boîte il ya
aussi deux dès qu'ils vont me servir les
aussi un autre truc spécifique de dans
là je peux pas vous dire que c'est
vraiment une surprise et pour terminer
il ya la connexion à un site internet
dédié sur ce site internet par exemple
vous pouvez prendre une photo avec moi
après le spectacle ça va vous des tours
et vous placez avec moi il ya plein de
feu peu différente que vous pouvez
choisir vous pouvez les partager et
garder pour vous faire n'importe quoi
aussi avec la photo tout ça tout ça
c'est possible sur ce même site il ya
d'autres choses galles les invitations
ont virtualisé à vos amis et tous pour
venir le voir le spectacle chez vous où
vous voulez il ya le spectacle
évidemment sur le site et il ya aussi
des rappels c'est à dire des morceaux de
spectacles bonus comme en vrai spectacle
si vous en voulez plus et belge enroule
bien faire un numéro bref là d'autres
choses à y compris ceux pour celles et
ceux qui se poseraient la question une
vidéo je vous explique comment ranger la
boîte à 0 pour refaire le spectacle à 0
ensuite si vous voulez le refaire ou le
revoir avec d'autres personnes ou alors
quand est-ce que ça sort ses sorties
vous l'avez dans toutes les librairies
les librairies habituel des petites
librairies de quartier vous l'avez aussi
dans les grandes enseignes les fnac les
cultures allées leclerc
certaines grandes surfaces aussi
d'ailleurs vous l'avez évidemment en
ligne sur la boutique brainstorm que
vous l'avez évidemment en ligne sur les
sites habituels en ligne comme amazon et
si vous aimez pas amazonia tous les
autres revendeurs fnac et sait aussi
qu'il aimerait vous voyez chez beaucoup
de trop excité ce sera peut-être votre
cadeau de noël ou un cadeau à vous faire
à vous même mais vous pouvez dire ça ça
n'existait pas on l'a fait depuis avril
au taquet dessus d'un site très heureux
on a fait aussi un petit teaser je vous
mets juste à la fin de cette vidéo comme
ça vous verrez un peu le décor et pouces
appareil ça va vous spoiler un tout
petit peu le lieu de tournage mais je
suis trop content d'avoir fait ça
j'espère que vous allez kiffer un show
interactif inédit où je suis pas là mais
c'est interactif quand même je suis trop
content vraiment merci la vie merci a
vous de me permettre de faire ce genre
de choses sans déconner on prend une
seconde pour ça
d'habitude moi il ya longtemps ses idées
qui me venait je pouvais rien l'enfer en
fait aujourd'hui je peux aller voir un
édité en disant j'ai des champs mais
aidez moi à produire ça et je sais qu il
le fait parce que il ya vous derrière en
fait il sait que parmi vous il y en aura
qui sont intéressés donc c'est
clairement des projets communs c'est
collectif c'est grâce à vous tous merci
beaucoup voilà c'est sais pas si des
fois on dit beaucoup merci on cherche un
mot plus fort mais n'y a pas de plus
fort donc merci d'être là merci de me
faire confiance à chaque fois de suivre
mes projets j'espère que vous allez vous
y intéresser surtout vous allez kiffer
faites moi vos retours dites moi tout ça
et faites-vous mentaliser on prenez soin
de vous à très bientôt chao teaser
salut je m'appelle fabien olicard et je
fais une pente à nice mme sur scène
depuis des années mais aujourd'hui ça va
changer je vais faire directement chez
vous vraiment chez vous dans votre salon
il est enfermé dans votre écran ce
nouveau show que je vous propose c'est
un show interactif disponible sur un dvd
est également en vidéo en ligne
accompagné d'une boîte qui est plein
d'accessoires dont va se servir vous et
moi durant le spectacle est accompagnée
également d'un livret contenant plein de
choses bonus bref je vais pas tout vous
dévoiler la seule chose que je peux vous
c'est que c'est un show complet inédit
qui aura lieu chez vous et vous pouvez
même inviter vos amis la boîte spectacle
est disponible dans toutes les enseignes
habituelles chez vos libraires chez les
grands magasins est également en ligne
alors rendez vous chez vous dans votre
salon
vous y attendre vrai que c'est plus
petit qu l'olympia avec le zénith de
paris mais c'est plus confortable
[Musique]